more than 368 000 americans have lost
their lives due to coronavirus
complications
that surpasses the combat deaths we saw
in world war
ii by about 70 thousand
and here in clark county brian we are
reportedly among the worst in the
country for new
case growth if people aren't taking
covet 19 seriously
then this next story might help because
so many people are dying
our local mortuaries have had to bring
in extra
storage sasha loftis spoke with the
owner of a funeral and cremation service
tonight she joins us live to share
what the industry is actually seeing
denise and brian it's just really a
reality we can't ignore
because we are seeing so many covid 19
deaths here at the clark county
coroner's office
that of course means a higher demand for
burials
i spoke with someone today who's worked
in the local funeral industry for about
13 years
she says she's never seen anything like
this
there's consequences you know really
tragic consequences
it's a scene we don't want to set after
losing a loved one to kovit 19.
i've never seen anything like this
before
i don't think anyone has but
unfortunately it's happening
at a rapid rate no one including laura
sussman
saw coming we had double what we
normally see and now
starting in january we're seeing even
more it could be triple what we normally
see
she's talking about bodies due to
coronavirus deaths
her funeral and cremation company has
seen so many in the last few months
they had to order this refrigerated unit
from the clark county corner
just to house them all every day they're
working on
taking care of these bodies that have
been infected on tuesday nevada reached
a new record of
60 deaths clark county's coveted numbers
also ranked among the worst in the
nation according to the cdc's latest
report
you see the families going through so
much pain but it's also stressful
because we have to
be very careful it's why sussman isn't
just asking
but begging people to take precautions
because it will
save lives it will make a big difference
and
i could get a little sleep at night and
people could live
now you heard laura mention her staff
being careful now when they do
receive a body that has died due to
covid19 complications there is a chance
it can still transmit the virus so of
course all of her employees have to wear
full ppe
so they don't risk contracting colvid 19
as well
for now reporting live in las vegas
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now